the commander of Russia's Black Sea
fleet has been shown attending a video
conference a day after Ukrainian forces
said they'd killed him Victor sokolov
was seen taking part in a meeting with
the defense minister in video released
by Moscow on Monday Ukraine's Special
Forces said they had killed sokolov
along with 33 other officers in a
missile attack on Crimea last week the
strike hit the headquarters of Russia's
Black Sea Fleet in the port of sabasa
fall over to Julia chapovalova in Moscow
Forest so Yulia what is Russia saying
about the fate of this Commander then
well when journalists asked Kremlin
sparksman demetriuskov about the rumors
of the death of the Commando the Russian
Black Sea Fleet he answered that there
had been no information on that from the
ministry of defense and later the video
appeared published by the Russian
Ministry of Defense it was filmed at a
regular meeting of the Ministries Board
of commanders so the metis was attended
by Victor sakolov commander of the Black
Sea Fleet who had actually been
pronounced dead by the Ukrainian side
sokolov participated there via video
conference alongside the commanders of
other fleets just to remind you the day
before the Ukrainian side claimed that
sokolo had been killed in a missile
attack on the Black Sea Fleet
headquarters in Sebastopol the attack
took place last Friday on September the
22nd the Russian Ministry of Defense
acknowledged that attack and reported
one serviceman missing and since then
the Russian side hasn't given any
updates on the number of casualties
there while according to Ukraine who had
carried out their tag 34 Russian
officers were killed 105 military
personnel were injured and the
headquarters building was badly damaged
and just a while ago Ukraine kept
insisting that they had killed the
commander who recently heard from a
Ukrainian official speaking about
vulnerability of the Russian Black Sea
Fleet comparing the Russian Navy to
chicken running around without its head
so right now we are hearing reports that
the Ukrainian ciders are clarifying
the rumors about the death of the
Russian Commander so all that is not
surprising at all that during military
hostilities war inside always tried to
diminish their capabilities often
spreading rumors about each other Julia
thank you Julia chapovalova in Moscow